Devastating earthquake
in Turkey and Syria.
It struck before
dawn and collapsed buildings
while people were asleep in their beds.
And just moments ago.
We just got
word of a powerful 7.5
magnitude aftershock.
There you can see people digging
through the rubble.
More than 1300 people now reported dead.
And there's fear
the death
toll could potentially climb
into the tens of thousands.
Right now,
this desperate search
underway for survivors trapped
under giant piles of concrete
Dramatic video showing rescuers
pulling a bloody toddler
out of the rubble in northwest Syria.
This is an area
already traumatized and ravaged
by the bloody and horrific civil war.
Here's the moment.
One child was rescued from that rubble
Boy, I'll get it in
oh, I love
my clothes.
Want to get the latest now.
Jomana Karadsheh
is tracking
the latest developments from Istanbul.
Jomana, good morning to you.
What do we know this hour?
Don, absolutely devastating.
Major earthquake,
as you mentioned, a 7.8 magnitude
earthquake that struck
essentially in the middle of the night
at about 4:00 in the morning
while people were indoors in bed.
It was so powerful
that it was felt
across the region in different countries,
including Lebanon, and Israel, Jordan.
And as you mentioned, it was so powerful
that we are looking
now at these major aftershocks
that have followed
at least 30
so far,
reported the strongest
just in the past
half hour, a 7.5 magnitude.
The authorities are urging people
to stay away from structures
as we heard from the Turkish president.
Nearly 1000 people have been confirmed
killed in Turkey.
Thousands others injured.
There's fear for so many others
who are potentially trapped underneath
the rubble.
I mean, we're talking about
an area, Don, that stretches across
southern Turkey.
Ten provinces,
at least
and across the border
into northwestern Syria as well.
So many cities and towns
devastated in both these countries.
More than 1300 people confirmed killed in
both Turkey and Syria.
And this frantic rescue effort is ongoing
right now.
Of course, a race against time
with only a few hours of daylight left.
I mean, you can just see it's obvious
the danger there.
So one has to wonder
how did how do officials
even begin
to these rescue efforts
under such conditions?
Well, look, Don, you've got
these two
simultaneous disasters
that this region
is dealing with right now.
What is happening here
in Turkey,
in a country
that is very experienced
in dealing with natural disaster,
it has a history of devastating
earthquakes, tens
of thousands of people
who have been killed
in major earthquakes over the years.
The last one,
according to President Erdogan,
this is the major, first major disaster
on the level of the last one
seen in 1939.
But you have the capabilities here.
And at the same time, Turkish
officials are declaring this
a level
four emergency,
which means they have requested
international support
and international support is coming.
You've got Nieto, the E.U.
45 countries,
according to President Erdogan,
that have offered to help
you've got Turkish
search and rescue teams
that are very experienced
in dealing with this
who have been deployed
to the earthquake zone.
You've got the military
that has also been deployed
the biggest concern right now,
of course, you've got many challenges
they're facing, including the weather.
There's a winter storm,
a severe winter storm
that is impacting
the that part of the country right now.
And also trying to reach these
areas with many different
airports also impacted in the region.
And a lot of concern, Don,
I must mention, for Syria, a country
where services
and infrastructure is decimated
by more than a decade of war.
They really don't have the capabilities
to deal with this right now.
You see rescue workers on the scene here.
Jomana Karadsheh is reporting this.
She's in Istanbul.
We'll check back with you
on this very deadly earthquake next hour.
So let's go to our meteorologist
Chad Myers to talk about
what was just recorded Chad.
And that is the aftershock.
The original quake, 7.8.
This aftershock huge 7.5 magnitude.
An earthquake in itself.
Yeah.
Would have been the strongest earthquake
since 1999 in the region.
Now, we always talk about the epicenter,
but we really in this case,
we should talk about the line.
Here's the original 78.
Here's the new 75.
About 100 miles
from one side to the other.
This earth slipped
and this earth slipped in what we call
a strike slip where the plates
are touching
And all of a sudden they slide sideways.
So the initial
the primary movement
is the building moving sideways
and then moving back.
Unlike when we have the ring of fire,
where we have
these subduction plates
and sometimes
plates will go up and plates will go down
causing the tsunamis.
This is more of a sliding back and forth
Why that matters is because the buildings
don't want to go back and forth.
And then the secondary waves
can begin to go up and down as well.
There is the strike
where the heaviest damage
will be right now
from the initial from the initial quake.
The new quake is far enough
away from the first quake.
About 60 miles
that we will see
more damage in other areas as well.
Two plates collide here.
This is
one of the areas that we expect
this type of scenario
It hasn't happened in a long time,
especially not a 7.8.
And we talked about the weather
the reporter just did
about how this very, very cold
temperatures around 40.
We will see snow in the forecast,
especially where the new earthquake was.
It's a much higher elevation,
almost 2000 feet higher in elevation
than where the original quake was.
This will be a very difficult, long
and tragic recovery.
Poppy.
You're right to add that aftershock,
a big earthquake in and of itself.
Thank you for that.